endings beginnings there's a lot of
improvisation
in this film which i would imagine
takes a lot of i would say courage as an
actor to do that much improvisation
because
then the director can if you're if
you're improvising a scene
for 20 minutes and the director can cut
it down to
two they have a lot of control over
what happens yeah you're completely
right i mean
the good thing is that our director
drake deremus
most of his films that he's improvised
not most of
he hasn't improvised all of his films
the films that he has improvised
are incredible and i'm a huge fan of and
he's he's just somebody who really cares
about people
and about emotions and about humanity
and love and
suffering and pain and and i think that
you know being in one of his movies you
kind of know what you sign up for
um you're completely right and we will
do scenes for 20 minutes
and then he'd come up to us and say hey
i really liked this sentence and i like
this sentence
how do we now put these two sentences
and make a new scene out of them and so
the whole thing got like one big improv
improvisational still not say that word
experiment uh and we really got to know
ourselves very well
because when you are improvising you're
pulling from your own well of
knowledge and experience and i think you
surprise yourself with some of the
things you say sometimes
wow i would prefer a script
yeah you know i think it was a different
director a script would be nice but with
this girl
it felt great i know i mean it's it's
really cool that you did that i just
think
uh and i'm i'm not an actor but i would
to be an actor and have to excavate your
own feelings
and probably mind your past and
try and feel things and exp you know
expose parts of yourself i'd be like
can i have a script please yeah i mean
it was
really vulnerable super vulnerable i
feel like i got to know
those actors and our crew as well
because they were improvising the whole
time in many ways
more than i've ever gotten to know any
other actor or crew on any film set
wow okay so um this i want to make sure
i
get this out there because this is
endings beginnings is now available
digitally on all platforms and video on
demand
i like to call that vod i don't think
anybody else calls it vaude
i'm the only person all right well i
worry about you because you're alone in
a house with a dog
for a very long time i will come out of
this
okay i promise maybe you like this maybe
some people enjoy this because they're
kind of shy so
i love it i love it i mean i can do the
whole extrovert thing if i have to but
i'm such an introvert
and this feels like a cozy cocoon so i'm
very happy
all right hey thank you so much for
doing this take care of yourself
i will you too and uh we'll see you on
the other side of this craziness
yes you hopefully you're not gonna give
my best to the dog
i will give my best to your family